I really try not to give advice on the  channel because I think every person's  different and I can't tell you how to  live your life I will say I do think  that some of the girls that have been on  their the channel see the world  differently and I know for a fact like  girls that are closer to me definitely  understand the men's point of view a lot  more and that's my main goal for the  channel is to have women understand the  men's point of view because I think life  is a lot easier when you can understand  the other sex and understand where  they're coming from and us as women like  men have always had to understand where  we're coming from in order to get laid  or get in a relationship but like women  don't have to do that so I just think  life is easier when you understand where  people are coming from